foreign
it's just a little squid gamey in here
[Music]
this is Garten of
Bam Bam
Garden of banban one not two oh why so
loud shut up oh my God oh my God that's
piercing
I know I know it's too loud I know there
we go
okay so we're gonna look into Garden of
ban ban what is Garden of ban ban you
don't need to know a garden of ban ban
is all you need to know is a garden of
ban ban is here to keep you company
for a parent looking for their missing
child time is
Jesus Christ time is a delicate matter
click the clock to advance time
what what
what oh
boots
all right proceed interact okay
ban bans kindergarten
hold shift to Sprint I got a blue key
card
jumbo Josh says eat vegetables and
fruits to become strong like me
well let's be perfectly honest uh it's
good for you but it's really Protein
that's gonna make you big and stronger
is obvious actually
is that a drone
what do they do in giving a drone to
children
uh
dear Mommy I am hiding in a room but I
have to fight the monster it is the only
chance to make Claire like me
what
[Laughter]
okay all right good
good good
great
wow
nice cafeteria just vending machines no
no kitchen
Stinger Flynn says having many arms
allows me to help a lot more people yeah
a battery
I bet that's for the Drone I bet if I
put that in the Drone
everything will be hunky-dory never mind
I was wrong I'm stupid
I'm just a stupid idiot
turns out I'm a [ __ ] can I not open
this
there are no way to open this
e
e I'm eating as hard as I can e
I'm eating I'm pressing I'm pushing I'm
pressing ball controls here we go
eat nope that's it
wait right click left click
I really want to hey am I missing
something am I stupid
my gamer instincts is telling me that
I'm missing something but I couldn't
possibly be missing something I'm far
too smart and way too handsome to be
foreign
oh
you go over okay
okay interesting
foreign
okay so I need to do something with this
drone obviously so I need to make this
drone go somewhere and somehow oh
are these buttons
hit it
nice
hit it
what oh
okay
hey
kill it kill it kill it kill it kill it
kill it kill it kill it oh kill it oh my
God kill it oh kill it kill it kill it
kill it oh God
foreign
toy cannot be directly commanded to
breakable materials such as yellow glass
ban ban says sharing is caring
[Music]
okay sure
sure the naughty corner I see
so it can't go in the yellow glass
oh
hit
the end is here
interesting
huh
okay I guess I gotta go across the room
to this horrible Place Captain fiddle
says ooga booga booga ooga
Bon bolina says kindness is free so
sprinkle it everywhere great
oh it's fine it's just a little squid
gamey in here kill it kill it kill it
kill it dead
kill it dead kill it dead kill it kill
it kill it kill it kill it kill it
opila bird is unbelievably hungry feed
it six eggs to get your prize
why is there a hand on your why are
there hands why are you so veiny oh my
God it's the Loom from Spore this is
literally the m
my God it actually is I can't believe it
find eggs to feed opila bird
is this an egg
oh
horrible
horrible
oh horrible
horrorable
horrible
good
great
can I slide
nope great
good
and great let me know if you guys see an
egg you better shout it out really
loudly
bring a friend day caution heal slowly
caught another one did you see one I
don't hear any screaming
[Music]
I'm not hearing enough screaming if you
guys really found one you would be
screaming very loudly
can I pick it up no there we go
oh
whoa
what did that do
what did that do did that turn that on
no go get it
go get it
get it
kill
oh you did what'd that do oh
it was brighter for a second oh
no that's just hey oh
is that what that blue button did ah
I see
well I think that was four
um
did you guys see you guys see you guys
saw something did you see something
swing set
definitely no no maybe no yes no you
fools
you fools you lied to me in the hole
did you lie you lied you lied to me ah
egg
okay I think there's one more
there's got to be one more egg around
here somewhere so everybody keep your
eyes peeled
keep your peepers
oh never mind that was all of them claim
my reward at the mouth
I don't know if I want to
what is that money did I get money oh
it's a card
fine
a destructive tool is needed to remove
the planks I'm sure it is I'm sure that
that's what I need a destructive tool
foreign
[Music]
what did it do
what did it do
get it
[Music]
huh good is this a gun oh it's just a
hammer
distraction at one what do you mean
what are you talking about
what do you mean
there's something over there
something in there
oh
I hate it
I hate it all
um I hate it all I hate all of it I hate
all of it
don't do anything
interesting
wow this is a big place what the hell is
this supposed to be
we're supposed to jump but why though
opila bird said laughter is the best
medicine so make sure to smile
oh look at that
oh
do I hop on I think I hop on
I'm on
what is that
oh
good
good
no no
but why though
oh
but why but why
but why
what was my color what do you mean
no you were red
okay you're red you were
you were pink I believe
you were no you were pink
you were pink you were blue I remember
that
you were oranges
were you
yeah and that must mean you were green
you were big green guy because you
wanted people to eat their vegetables
green did I already pass Green Oh god
there it was so you must have been white
or something
[Music]
oh
I'm so goddamn good
I'm so goddamn good look at me
what
oh why what is
kill it kill it kill it kill it kill it
[Music]
get ahead
[Music]
no don't you do it don't you do it don't
you freaking do it no no no I'm
dangerous I'm lethal I'll kill you I'll
eat your face off I'll bite your whole
neck
Twain
what do I do what do I do oh
foreign
[Music]
that might have been one of the best
skiers I've experienced in a long time
what in the hell what was it even
thinking what was it what was it even
thinking of doing something like that
nope nope okay we ah man I already knew
about that come here you
bow
that's a little too close okay but if I
uh wait I'm just gonna I know this is
crazy oh God I can't get over there okay
um
hit it that's great that's great hit it
faster
are you kidding me are you kidding hit
hit it hit it hit it
[Music]
oh I jumped Too Short hey it's fine it's
Ryan
oh my God it's fine it's fine emergency
stop
so what's up with this
well
easy as pie nothing to it but to do it
huh
all right
I thought I was gonna have a challenge
over here
[Laughter]
[Music]
what the hell
oh
[Music]
well that's not nearly as fun
okay whatever
uh we have a note boarding pass uthman
Adam Montreal Madrid
aborting of the day 23 it's a QR code
don't scan it everybody you better not
B13 to 323 B13 and 323 all right
whatever
so what did that do for me
hello
I see you down there
don't stop
try that button
can't press that what would that do
oh
uh
oh
[Music]
oh
wow
for you
was that really for me what was it all
for me
is that all for me oh thanks
hello for me
yeah
all for me
hey wait
how long has that been there what whoa
whoa whoa wait whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
hey whoa hey whoa
what is happening
uh
huh
oh
aha
[Music]
oh
okay well
um this is great not the best design I
don't think
um but it never mind it's great design I
love it what a design
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you mean
oh hey wow
oh
I see
[Laughter]
ah good that was great I thought that
was great that was fantastic The Garden
of Bonbon of bonban the garden of bun
bun really good really good stuff really
high quality stuff I like that a lot
I like that so much I can't wait for
garden too loud get out of here I can't
wait for garden to Bonbon too really
really incredible stuff
truly spectacular I have the hiccups now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]